Ugh, I have to make this vinegar with a beautiful heart, but as I continued milling,
how did the music and flavor change so that it turned out to be
such a good food?
[Music] Uh-
uh-uh-ohyeah
[Music]
Jun-Jeong Ong-Nan Hani is making vinegar
We eat a lot of it because we always eat it with food, but we
always throw it away and drink a cup of Caesar at the end
I think the history of vinegar in Korea is about 3,000 years now to defrost it
In other words, I have been using watermelon for 20 years. What I am
making in Korea is made in a building.
Vinegar is a living organism just like a human being, so we have to respect that bacteria very
well and raise it well.
No, I don't like music, but that's because this
creature is very human
too
For those who have a sore throat, those who have a problem with their plaques, this kind of person
is very burned and depressed
Because he is also very healthy, I hope that this will
continue to be passed down so that it can help many people
[Music]